Hausa gum resumes parrot bad welcome
back to another episode two caves pity
oh god [ __ ] I don't really know what to
do exactly I'm kind of forgot what we
were doing here oh yeah we found the key
all right
the only known King goes to the
infirmary oh I don't like this oh god
this is bad but who said that who was it
hello its reaction no it was Naomi don't
be naive
don't be no sorry I tried
let's just save here because I haven't
feel like something bad is gonna happen
there's never been anything good in this
room except ass drooling you have no
idea what I'm talking about me neither
it's okay
is she gonna sleep no no bit oh yeah
that's what they said before Sokka oh my
Moscow sheis indica oh god damn it but
I'm gonna take of course Scott the lying
uh-huh he took the awesome God wait did
I make a wrong decision here seen by us
nah yeah exactly
I'd won him on Italy Oh goddamn it she's
so cute
just knowing that she got brutally
murders is horrible ah see Donna I guess
they all would starve to death
eventually sounds about right
okay tow mater cara cara nya it stopped
huh Syrian village oh hi Jovie de cette
année de cerdo
now me Iost Itachi Nakamoto goryeo deck
reba stone on Akali hoho vamoose Karsa
hey dotty estoy yo abro dice knows Bao's
a duty Rojas da man we know how that
worked out for us a Pakeha hikakin ano
nee pora gotcha mo can borrow LAN token
Arzo simple Serena nothing really bad
happened to them yet so I understand
their optimism but yeah yeah cherish it
out yet
so you gonna sleep yep you go still
don't open our madam Archon I come not
your Tod huh so he's honest to himself
and these Genji thoughts keep it stuck
in which car all mota night coming on
your new secret Obara god damn it Naga
sorry demo Akira Tommy nice engine guess
so
Oh what is this is he having nightmares
Chivo decay was Shinya Yamanaka Chingy
Kyoko - ah ah oh oh he's got captured
right are we gonna play as him Oh what
what
Oh oh no not those but we help them they
should be nice well they're not the ones
that took him there I hope your lives I
like him
come on it's not that funny
they're looking at my skirt in there
laughing handfuls she says it's not that
funny
what oh he's coming oh no oh no I think
he's the principal
what are you roasting can I move you
better do something quick man oh god oh
god oh god what happened
oh no no what
what no come on I wanna know ah Chaplin
with auto stationed at the god Nonya 10
over who don't need a dose room now come
on don't be so hard on yourself that oh
she she yes oh she remembers where they
are yeah that's gotta be horrible oh uh
uh uh Nakada moscow Chaka Khan Honda
now you guys are [ __ ] I'm sorry
Virginia Katara complete oka TR Cara
rock-candy with the what the green cat
no I mean yes all the way cover that up
to that all yes yet I saw coid thought
that him Illumina food gets its like
mindset hahaha invade aha
Shinohara kadar go Nakamoto he sure doto
eage Macedo kokoro Osorio Dogon Jojo
Nikon ha well everyone has been impaired
so far except the teacher Skaar
economica ya see me Nemo dr. creo Oh
sponsor I'm skank
um alright we're good Oh gel no no no
let's say I don't trust anything in this
game you never know what's gonna hate me
why did I say [ __ ] sorry okay
let's check this out there's a section
of old newspaper on the floor ladies all
right heavenly posts for children
abducted and killed follow up report the
brutal shocking deaths of the reason
konami grade schoolers have now been
traced back to the hands of the
instructor instructor found in the room
with them a large pair of suing scissors
were found in his possession we've heard
this before but wonder oh yeah and these
were confirmed to be the tool used in
removing the victims tongues ultimately
leading to death through excessive
bleeding or choking oh man that's
disgusting
one of the victims even had him the
majority of over head slowly
methodically remove this cranial mass
was found on the floor next to her body
of these chillin one was mm-hmm-hmm
when investigators arrived at the scene
of the crime I wonder if there is one of
us she was a little bit but some have a
little the heavenly the paw Adam I don't
know what to make out of that the
newspaper sworn at this point debate in
May for the a ticket is me eighteen look
like the one we saved in the last
episode hola - hola no koto catchable
look WA suck you know you do Donna oh so
they are the victims but why are they
still mean me they made notes in red
friends killed by Spurs law purpose
spread of the curse
gathering it's probably the girl who did
this the freaky one children's with no
tongues
girls with top of head missing girl in
red dress girl victim grudge gave shape
to school building escape interesting
very interesting I don't know what to
make out of that but I guess we got
fighter so the guy oh oh
who's that she knows she knows a key we
know it's not gonna be oh god oh god oh
we're so [ __ ]
we are so very perked sticky breasted
you that could be anything
something we're more likely someone or
drag down to heaven
okay I'd what's this there's a metal
tool or some source to get out yes
why not okay I remember there's an
there's a door in the beginning cool all
right well now we can progress okay I
don't like this so this is where she's
gonna splatter I don't like it I don't
want to know that she let me just for
safety's sake I don't know maybe crashes
or some [ __ ] it's annoying if you got a
replay oh god I can't walk here I don't
know why well I guess I'm following the
voices hi sexy you get her often oh good
what do you breasts think it's gonna
happen that's the thing about this you
never know that's when you know it's
good here it is alright the boys
bathroom
the door is boarded up with tightly
hammer nails he won't open have
convenient yes all at once you got Yosh
comes off no need to hold it in
oh yeah she really had to pee oh my
theory of the bucket its old ruin
goddamnit please please don't work yes
the pee bucket is happening oh my god I
know what courtesy Allah Oh God Oh
Horace otro India Turkish ah gommendy
kiyohara so la gente esta Dora
oh really
Luisa the nail she's got the night will
deliver when I I can normally pee but I
can't pee from boats I like I can't pee
from anywhere but if I don't know I
guess it's different if your little girl
what is this victim memorize alright
three out of five meet you how to
perfect pronunciation I know really
isn't any way to be feigned
is he I guess it's true I probably never
see him again but I may have figured out
a way of getting can't equate him at
last he left me a message on the teach
of death in one of the classrooms looks
like looks like even when we're in
different spaces we can still come here
to keep date way oh sorry about that
that's my skype but it's not an if
there's no warmth to be felt from
Brennan oh okay
I miss our fights our impromptu
wrestling matches of course but it's not
just a physical contact but I want more
than anything to see his face again this
is a love story I just want to be able
to see him around make small talk ask
him how it's been and what it plans to
do after school
those simple everyday interactions are
some of my most precious memories now
what I wouldn't give to have those back
days back sorry I could be funny what
runs through your head when you're
trying to make frostbitten fingers move
without cracking off wonderful truly
wonderful hey there's a unit roll can't
you pee in there I don't know how how it
works I don't like this oh yeah we were
on our way to the prepackaged my bad
how could I forget the pee bucket it's
my life has been spired every event oh
[ __ ] what happening someone take a
picture of me I wasn't ready
oh my gosh II said said super depressed
I would be like who took that picture
paparazzi's what what what the hell yeah
yeah
my polka oh it's him what stop oh my mom
pushed up oh god why did he sound so
happy just now I'll change they could
ask me out tonight I don't trust him one
second wise old or gentler why isn't the
bunny there why is the body there maybe
wasn't her I'm gonna be so happy
oh but it doesn't look different a
little bit doesn't it unions Stono
concise nah yo blue nickel America
oppressed but then a must be an older
female hockey us to do and that's why
you were taking pictures
Oh [ __ ] up [ __ ]
cocoa video katha Pocono astronautica
yeah Sachi Kiedis Cara's Amitabha Carla
so what's your basic wrapping the whole
time you got a movie tonight Joe my
Union wotty oh come on she's sitting
there
comfort her height
Auriga so vanity anakena in de y hips I
went what's going on here says no doctor
Oh Maya I got aa Dawson yummy service
cop yeah it's cold on a hookah Oh Connie
at sternal saw goody tomorrow aren't you
yeah and I was dying fine go ahead Jamie
pocket ah yeah ah today Latino ano KO
strea chao garden yatra so Connie you go
Syrian SATA gray well that sounds pretty
gain Wakita
I'm buddy doesn't go widows I don't
trust him one second is it throw up Dada
mean is your ego I'm really confused
there Eagle hey why was he taking
pictures like it doesn't make any sense
Oh God uh-oh oh yeah extraordinarily oh
god I don't like this we're going to the
pee bucket girl
we got one to pay back again my God why
did I pay back a commentary paper going
to be better go the pee bucket girl
tried to be dr. P buggin okay sorry I
try but I'm not good yeah fishing
baiting for come compliments anyway
let's read this mauka she wat a good god
junior student that's [ __ ] up so
there's children of all ages here it's
like Santa Claus all over again
ah here we go is it time
nope it's not tagged it's so weird
I understand alright well I guess we
keep keep looking I know there was
another place with nails wasn't it you
sincere we're gonna good you did you
gotta call me oh yeah that's what he
wrote yes I'm up today oh hello miss
Canova Mira Marcy I know P Oh Skeeter
let's good luck tomorrow all right so
you say say what's scary about Sunita oh
yeah they didn't get to talk to any
blues spirits so they don't really know
that much well a little bit actually so
Donna why don't you get me to cuddle God
look I don't like it well it sure as
hell doesn't seem like it words seem to
materialize I'll bring in the air just
above the desk self is barely
perceptible what look at their faces
unfortunately there's a very faint she
can make sensitive just change so we
have to wait a little bit use the nail
puller yes crash ha ha ha the Glasser is
now in pieces on the floor all around
you and we found a key Wow I'm so lucky
I literally just tried these things
randomly regrettably my neighbor were
broke
well at least we found some use for it
agreed a small key where are we gonna
put that where we're gonna put that
small key go I don't even rub a byword I
better buy it out there must be some
cabinet or some [ __ ] with his name
that's my best bet that looks lovely
doesn't it
let's do a little shave it we go all the
sudden 40 minutes I got her lost uh-huh
evil bad bunny oh yeah I know these shut
up evil bye bunny you don't know me you
little [ __ ]
Oh God this ambience it makes me hungry
hungry I know what's with my throat
pardon me pardon me pres um I guess we
just keep looking around I don't know
hmm
I'm trying to remember if there's any
cabinet oh maybe the infirmary they have
some cabinets but not really locked are
they you sure you don't wanna pee in the
bucket this is all I want from this game
Oh oh this could be it yeah try the key
No mmm ah dad well that means the only
place is here so Ewing what do we got
here oh oh it's the hallway we found it
awesome everything is it Sam how are you
doing said the body of a feat we're
sorry ma'am of course we got a name tag
me coward naruse it's a back story to
all of them huh exit two doors it's
locked
can we use the key hmm so lucky so lucky
I didn't even check here before oh my
god wonderful let's go in brass
oh so now we're here cool oh my god
today but at least we're outside right
we could climb up the roof and get help
right Oh
feel so bad
so maybe she doesn't die after all yeah
do that oh oh well you should know your
school right I guess it's a different
school predicament yes
ah ah parlez look out savestate gotta
learn my sensei
sorry bye thank God I did what I could
oh cool a little bit different scenery
santo muy dog let you get farted oh why
yuck tomorrow night how about you exit
that place then kogai-sama sadhana yoga
ooh my soto de ma te papa
Luka no caution hoga not a hunter in a
conjugal sings oh no she wants to stay
with us no locket they'll see by Cinda
you sure need a guy
no okay would it be even doing here
let's say station
ha ha ha train station
this one is going on for a long time
Jesus all right cabinet what do we get
rattle rattle ooh
rattle rattle rattle shatter oh that's
go in here cool finally some new scenery
Jesus I was getting OH
ah just know the pee bucket is
inevitable it's happening
Oh oh my god it's gonna be so good bad
it's gonna be terrible what I've got
here boys lavatory any and all students
Ronald Emily's faculty will Sorelli
stuff all right well let's go in here I
feel like we're gonna run into that the
murderer oh Jesus this is huge you could
go up or down let's start down for like
this less likely of us dying dancing
okay cool
cold cool story bro hurts to move
fingers no strength to ride on disc
connects talk or sleep friend tendon in
leg cut bleeding badly
Oh a female students a letter said you
know she has a letter in your hand
lucky is fickle but I still have faith
in it luck is fickle that good-luck
charm I know it's stupid but I truly
believe it works so I know I'll see you
again Wow and if anyone else finds this
letter please wish your good luck for me
carick Kimura fantastic feel so bad for
everyone it's like everyone who came
here died literally I I really think
everyone is gonna die I don't know but I
want I want I want them to live it's not
family girls lavatory come on seriously
the other just [ __ ] with this it
can't be they really want her to pee on
the floor on the float one what 1975 do
the repetition earn from repeated tragic
incident an accident in and around the
school plans for its abolition have been
finalized there has been a sharp decline
in registration in attendance since the
initial incidents indicating to the
school board that our time is at an end
we sincerely regret to announce that
heavenly host elementary school will
close the store for the last time on
November the 18th 1975 it is thought my
own vices that this this painful
decision has come to pass and for that I
must offer my deepest apologies to all
those affected filed to all teaching
staff principal
all right we're going really deep here
that's my cheesy everything is new
hair's uh I'm really confused by it
cursed our groom how do we know it's
cursed Oh God
[ __ ] that Oh God No Oh meet up tonight
safe mm-hmm mm-hmm we do not do that
who the hell are you what is your sense
of judgment what is blue look at this
art instead you know i press my deeply
sorry but we got to have to end this
episode here um I hope you enjoyed
watching that we like if you did and I'm
sorry for a little short episodes I mean
Italy it's complicated for me to make
videos here but I wanted to do it for
you bros so go ahead and leave a like me
know I'm watching I really appreciate it
it makes you feel good and make my
nipple sketch and everyone is just happy
that way so stay awesome Rose thank you
for watching as always your lace happy